a young woman at a club and she came to
my hotel room she sped over her legs and
it smelt like hot blood like it was it
was like autopsy it was like it was like
a crime scene she opened it up I was oh
[ __ ]
so it was old you know it was like old
and and but she was young it just
smelled like blood was old bla bla it
smelt like you know a crime scene and I
and I still did it because I think it's
more because I didn't want to hurt her
feelings
rights and when I smelt it and I think
she saw my face Co you know me like I
saw like the devil or something right
then I went in because of because of my
my you know I have a good morality time
when you flick the poo play the guitar I
don't want to say her name of course the
girl the hippies to play with a guitar
they and they always have a hippie with
the guitar and she was like singing all
the time
and then like we're in love we're in la
jolla and it was during the day and I
was doing her doggy style and she said
she turned her on and she goes I just
had a vision and I go what and I'm still
having sex with her and she goes um I
envisioned that you and I had a family
in the middle of [ __ ] you yes the baby
and a white picket fence hmm and then I
smelled something weird so relaxed so I
was like yeah and I did I smell
something and I spread over her cheeks
and she had five hairs normal I know but
not but they weren't curled you know
mean they were like Asian hair sticking
up yeah they were just like porcupine
you know like you know like if you see
like
a scary movie yeah and the hairs on the
back of your neck but they were yeah
they were sticking out of the back this
you know I mean like they were at a rave
and they were like wait great hair yeah
rave Harris on the tip of one of them
was a perfect ball of pool right but it
was little but it was dangling from like
how big like a piece of rice corn rice
and you put into a ball maybe to like a
peppercorn that's a good one I got the
pink ones I got the green ones white
ones did you know the black poor kids
who have like anxiety issues they can't
afford prozac or in the stuff and they
smell peppercorn is supposed to ease
your anxiety so more people use it and I
use it sometimes so in fact when you're
high on marijuana and you we're smoking
you mean weeds yes right and and you
have they say when you have a panic
attack when you just smell pepper yeah
so that's just FYI yeah yeah it's a
delicious of thing so anyway so she had
a little you look like a jazz a flower
you know I mean it's like a little ball
at the end right and she as soon as she
said that I had a vision of going to CVS
right now and getting toilet paper
evidence that you just flicked it yeah I
flicked it like that right yeah I saw a
flier on a fly across the room but you
know what I feel because I feel bad you
know now that you say that she was a
nice girl is way no no no a nice girl I
did like her yeah and then I remember
she was it the first time you had sex no
we had sex probably 10 times
well you didn't like
like they're that much because yeah you
if it's ten times in and you can't tell
who is what you can't change her for me
you got it you don't like her that much
exactly yeah you blinked it yeah I
wanted out of my vision yeah yeah so I
flicked it and then what she had moved
from a different city to be with me
right and and I remember driving her
back thinking to myself I'll never see
her again and so I remember like a year
later she showed up at a comedy club and
she just looked at me and she looked
that's 40 and maybe I don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
however being very cool to her I this is
why I know for sure you didn't like her
as much as year as maybe you thought
because you like poo your brother and
you were obsessed with a smell of poo in
fact and we'd talk about this you know
about the first time I met your brother
he came to my house and almost pooped on
a friend of mine willingly willingly I
mean my brother my brother Steve yes
your brother Steve